ils sont partout à tous les coins de rue
des mégots indésirables qui pourrait
bientôt coûter très cher à celui qui
s'en débarrasse
je pense que c'est du vol cetto parce
que 68 euros pour un mégot mois se
souviendra m'arriver ben je laval le
mégot il aurait pas les 60 tuto rouge ou
dit tout de suite ouvrière et d'où la
gto en général en général par terre mais
il va falloir que je fasse attention
maintenant eh oui monsieur il va sans
doute bientôt falloir penser au cendrier
car la mairie d'orléans réfléchit à
verbaliser les fumeurs indélicat à paris
ou à cannes l'amande s'élève déjà à 68
euros
c'est très bien qu'ils aient des villes
qui régissent lalonde qui a réagi à
cannes il ya paris c'est très bien je
pense que si toutes les villes s'y
mettent
il y aura une prise de conscience et il
y aura peut-être une modification du
comportement il faut bien avoir
conscience que ce sont les âges hommes
espaces publics qui ont subi ce site
toutes les conséquences ce sont les
balayeurs ce sont les agents de la
voirie et ça c'est voilà la moindre des
choses c'est les respecter aussi
et si rien n'est encore acté du côté
d'orléans la municipalité souhaite
d'ores et déjà systématiser les
cendriers devant tous les bâtiments
publics